let's talk about WikiLeaks Donald Trump
cited WikiLeaks dozens of times during
the 2016 campaign he even said he loves
WikiLeaks and now the White House is
saying it was all a joke or I guess like
a dozen or sixteen jokes because he
cited or praised WikiLeaks more than a
dozen times and the context of all of
this is Julian Assange's arrest in
London last week Donald Trump had dozens
of times mentioned WikiLeaks
citing their work but now he's saying
with WikiLeaks I know nothing about
WikiLeaks it's not my thing
which is a really weird thing for Donald
Trump to say given that 141 times he had
mentioned WikiLeaks before the 2016
election the Moller report according to
the bar summary establishes that
WikiLeaks was a sort of middle person
for documents illegally hacked from the
DNC and Hillary Clinton by Russia and
Trump cited them countless times there's
that infamous I love WikiLeaks back in
October of 2016 there's when Trump said
we've learned so much from WikiLeaks
this WikiLeaks is a treasure trove many
tweets about this were Donald Trump's
sites WikiLeaks including where he said
very little pick up by the dishonest
media of incredible information provided
by WikiLeaks there are many tweets I
won't read them all to you but here's a
few video examples of Donald Trump's
love for WikiLeaks before Julian Assange
was arrested of course WikiLeaks I love
WikiLeaks this wiki Lea stuff is
unbelievable it tells you the inner
heart you got to read it it's been
amazing what's coming out on WikiLeaks
this WikiLeaks is faster than this
WikiLeaks it's like a treasure trove
getting off the plane they were just
announcing new WikiLeaks and I wanted to
stay there but I didn't want to keep you
waiting where I love reading those
WikiLeaks he just loved it right wick
with WikiLeaks what's wicked I don't
know anything about Julian Assange some
guy got arrested he'll have to get a
lawyer or something like that
so we've well established that Donald
Trump knows about likes and is familiar
with WikiLeaks already here Sarah
Huckabee Sanders saying everything you
just saw and heard the video I played
for you the tweets I put up on the
screen the quotes I read to you those
were
all jokes and I don't even know what
that means like what does it mean to say
that he was joking that he cited
something that was published and he was
he wasn't really citing it even though
the citation was accurate or that he was
citing it but he was joking that it was
from WikiLeaks even though it really was
I don't know in what way that can all be
a joke but that's what Sarah Huckabee
Sanders claimed yesterday what the
president said about WikiLeaks during
the campaign and then this week
WikiLeaks I love WikiLeaks this
WikiLeaks is like a treasure trove where
I love reading those WikiLeaks I know
nothing about WikiLeaks it's not my
thing how can the president say he knows
nothing about WikiLeaks remember
lightning-round and does he regard
Julian Assange as a villain or a hero
look clearly the president was making a
joke during the 2016 campaign certainly
we take this serious in fact our
administration is the only one that's
done anything about it let's not forget
that the reason Julian Assange is being
looked at is because of the engagement
he had with Chelsea Manning that
individual is the person that the Obama
administration actually commuted their
sentence
yeah go go look at what Obama did we
take this serious do they not realize
Pat that the internet archive's
audio-visual evidence of things that
people say like do or do they just not
think that their base and Fox News knows
how to look stuff up on the internet or
will care about it because this is this
is the gaslighting of America they're
definitely just playing to their base
here they know that the Republican
audience isn't going to take a look at
old Trump quotes and also they go to
this excuse all the time like when Trump
gave a State of the Union address and
many Democrats weren't clapping he said
that Democrats were committing treason
later they said that the president was
just joking I don't find Trump to be the
most funny character so I don't think
that excuse stands up to me yeah I've
never seen Donald Trump joke I mean he
seems to have a personality problem
where he actually doesn't have a sense
of humor so to write this office joking
is completely a historical Russia if
you're listening hack Hillary's emails
I love WikiLeaks well then Russia hacks
Hillary's emails gives them to WikiLeaks
and WikiLeaks releases them oh those
were all jokes jokes but
by the way Trump still benefited from
the entire thing it's not even clear
anymore whether Sarah Huckabee Sanders
knows the difference between a lie and
the truth you know when little kids have
to testify in court cases and they'll be
asked to establish their credibility
hey little Susie do you know the
difference between the truth and a lie
oh yes mr. attorney I do i don't think
sarah huckabee Sanders passes that test
and it's the continued gaslighting of
america if you love learning new things
you probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video